what's going on zendaya it's so good to
see you i'm good how are you i'm so
great uh this show i mean obviously fans
are so obsessed there's reddit threads
there's memes they're so invested help
me debunk two rumors about this past
season is it true we're gonna have to
wait until 2024 for season three i think
that might be true i honestly don't know
there's some um executives that know
better than me you might want to ask
them that's a long time i'm busy for a
while you are busy plus you need a break
from rue don't you feel like
yeah maybe a little healthy break yeah
um was tom holland an extra in the
audience during lexi's play oh who knows
the world might never know was it meant
to have someone like tom to help pull
you out of those dark moments as real no
it's i think it's great to have that
support and that love around you because
you need that you know this isn't an
easy easy job so it's good to have
that too to free you up from it every
now and then
the single from the finale inspired new
music um
maybe
all right thank you